broken characters in
any game suck they can invalidate the
rest of the cast
ruin ranked games with stupid cheese and
worst of all can be so brain dead and
easy to use that they're just
everywhere a broken character doesn't
just ruin your game
they can fundamentally change the way
the game is played and spoil it for
everyone
now sometimes a developer will save us
from their mistakes
other times well let's just say the top
few entries on this list
are still haunting us to this day here
are the top 10 most broken characters in
esports history
kicking off our list at number 10 is
league of legends most
recent balance mistake ophelios well
affilios is always a pleasure to
watch that's when he ends up when he
ends up doing it
200 years of collective pentakills
absolutely
incredible stuff now we all want to brag
when we get a pentakill but when a
fellows was released
doing that just felt wrong because the
champion and specifically their alt
combined with their flamethrower ability
were broken ultimate running keeps
himself alive for that empress divide
was absolutely fantastic it's nothing in
comparison
to mystic with his quadra kill though is
it going to be back-to-back benches
against sandbox in the first game it is
but the sad part is
it seems like riot built a compelling
champion with a pretty complex set of
abilities
maybe even too complex i have no
clue what i'm looking at i don't know
what's coming next i'm just i mean you
just approach them and you're guessing
you're actually just guessing and if the
pentakills were the result of
expert technical play instead of a
busted ultimate
maybe we'd all remember a felios as
super cool
instead of super broken taking the
number nine spot on our list is akuma
from tekken 7. i can't believe what
we're seeing and look at the life bar
oh my goodness he probably had a sliver
right
he might have a sliver oh my god
oh my god originally a street fighter
character akuma seemed like a strange
fit when he was added to tekken
because even though akuma was in a
tekken game he brought all his street
fighter tools to the party
so between his insane damage and just
generally breaking the rules that most
tekken characters follow
he was difficult to balance and guessing
oh my god that angle looked like it
could have reached flight could have
ended it right there
85 percent and akuma's ridiculous damage
eventually he was nerfed and while he's
still considered strong by many
the days of raging demon oppression are
gone
for now dota 2 is a game where you
usually just counter
really overpowered things with some
broken things of your own
but one hero stands out among even the
sea of broken nonsense
which is why release monkey king takes
number 8 on our list
the tuning on this hero was way off back
then
mk's boundless strike gave more crit
damage per level
he had more armor and jingu mastery had
no duration
but beyond just number problems monkey
king's
alt which creates over a dozen copies of
the hero
used to copy the effect of the skull
basher item
giving each one a chance to bash enemies
have fun not playing dota the second
that this chimp pressed r
at number seven on our list is release
xin zhao who
broke league of legends in one week
released in july 2010
xin zhao was initially a terrifying
blender of a character
with great base stats and an overtuned
kit he
terrorized summoner's rift
he had a charge that slowed enemies
approximately
40 feet away from him a buff that let
him knock enemies into the air every
three attacks
and a steroid that increased his attack
speed and reduced cooldowns
letting him do it all even faster and to
top it all off his alt was a
dead aoe attack that dealt extra damage
based on enemies current health
so yeah a hard-hitting disruptive highly
mobile melee attacker with a high attack
speed
very low cooldowns and some self-healing
once they were on you
you were pretty much dead at number six
is a character that is almost
unbelievably broken
pre-release twisted fate lock a gold
card in the fountain
destiny and then gate directly behind
them listen there's a reason that the
teleport summoner spell has a long
cooldown
moving across the map quickly is
something that shouldn't be happening
all the time but pre-release twisted
fate didn't care about the rules
he had a teleport on a very short
cooldown that was global
and unlike the summoner spell could
literally put him anywhere
here we start a new game with a new
level 6 gank again i'm within two
attacks of stacked deck
i've locked the gold card and i destiny
close to anivia
even with flash cleanse and rebirth my
damage output is just
too awesome gold cards stunned not only
the target
but everyone else around the target too
his passive was a team-wide crit chance
buff
and his wild cards ability had
incredible range
that let him abuse whoever was across
from him in lane basically the character
was incredibly strong and could show up
wherever he wanted
whenever he wanted to shove a gold card
down your throat
and walk away at the halfway point on
our list is lee roy smith
the most broken character in tekken
history
probably a bomb player formerly a geese
player
now he's using leroy surprise surprise
leroy was just too good he did too much
damage
his moves were too safe and in tekken a
fighting game scene known for
highly analytical players with vast
character and counterpick knowledge the
verdict was clear
at evo japan 2020 six of the top eight
players played leroy
fan favorites like me and jdcr were
eliminated by leroy players
yeah just pick me on i think
not too much damage they don't have
enough meter to really make that too
explosive here
orbital again it's not going to steal
that move it's too good to not use
so much damage little fist bump there
yeah
get rekt coming in at number four
is a lion from rainbow six siege target
acquired and now magnet knows exactly
where he has to cut off
he's also getting lion also getting ying
detected by the e1d neo cleans him up
see lion's gadget gave defenders a
choice if you moved during the duration
it outlined your location to the entire
enemy team
and in a game where intel is everything
and you can shoot through many walls
that's not good raphael using the smoke
and candela combo
is just going to push right in they'll
have some covering fire as the artillery
of glass stands in bathroom
and look at that rafael they will just
bully them vitality
sweeps into the site if you didn't move
well
you were probably about to get peaked
and killed never mind the fact that the
drone could be used once a site was
secure to make
re-takes extremely difficult the gadget
basically broke the rules of siege
what makes lions so powerful well a lot
of people say just stay still
but that's not easy when you're getting
flashed or pushed or jackled once
bands were introduced to pro play he
picked up an
insane 100 band rate before ubisoft put
him in
quarantine while they figured out how to
fix the mess they cause
the ee1d drone is now a much weaker
version of its former self and is mostly
overshadowed by other operators
but honestly we're okay with that
no one misses lion at his worst
our number three spot goes to smash's
second most broken character
bayonetta oh
after the initial hype of her
announcement it turned out that
bayonetta had a touch of death combo
that could be performed from nearly
anywhere on screen
add to that some incredible recovery and
other tricks like witch time
and the character was clearly overtuned
but while the initial nerf she received
made her less popular to casual players
she was still incredibly strong and
plenty of pros still used her
[Applause]
oh at evo 2018
the last smash 4 evo finals ever two
bayonetta players forced the game to a
standstill
after fans booed them for much of the
tournament what was going on
what is this i don't know i was stalling
for time all right man
i really understand why this is the last
evo
[Laughter]
that's even for you i mean i didn't
really get it eventually a to
forced them to keep playing but the
damage was done
thankfully bayonetta was pretty severely
nerfed for smash ultimate so the witch
truly is dead today it's pretty rare
that a consensus number one character
pick goes
unchanged for basically the game's
entire history but
in brawl one batty boy perched atop the
tier list from
day one meta knight and the glide attack
will do it
two stock from u2 king esam looking like
he is lost this is another character
that basically has
everything great damage easy kills
amazing recovery insane mobility
the only thing bad about meta knight was
that he was a bit of a glass cannon but
that hardly mattered
and the thing about mew2king is all he's
really doing is just letting esam hit
him
and it's it'll just if he sees asam
above him he'll just shield
and other than that muta king will just
stay in the air
and wait for esam to put out an attack
that there's nothing esam can do about
it
if any character was deemed to have a
bad matchup with meta knight
they probably weren't getting played too
often it got so bad
that the character was briefly banned
from pro play under certain tournament
rule sets
and the character's strong off stage and
edge guarding ability caused certain
stages to become banned as well
players like zero would be like the best
at this because xero would actually
actively practice doing this optimally
all the time
and i was probably the second best did
it and the worst part was that nintendo
never patched brawl
meta knight ruled the game from launch
to death
taking our top spot is the most broken
character in esports history
the character that destroyed an entire
league
brigitta when you see brigitta you think
that she's pretty much unkillable
because most dps characters that do all
the damage don't really
work against her brigitta was a
close-ranged healer with good defensive
capability
players were excited for a different
kind of support but while brigitte
definitely changed overwatch forever
it wasn't in a good way now mickey has a
rally if he can stay alive
doing lots of damage giving his team a
good amount to healing as well
getting a little bit low needs to be
careful here wow he's got the rally off
they actually kept him alive dallas she
was just too good at too many things
she did good damage could layer armor
onto her team's health bars
and she had good crowd control the new
meta brigitta created was called
ghosts and it featured three tanks and
three supports on each team
no damage just big bodies and endless
healing
chat i cannot imagine what it's like to
be a pro player right now
cha to chat i want you to think of this
okay people and pro players scrimmed
this meta
probably six to eight hours a day there
was no reason to play damage with
brigitte around
so no one did goats made the overwatch
league into a snooze fest and
significantly impacted viewership we do
see the outlaws are going to pull out
dante's tracer this has been some of the
things that outlaws fans were waiting
for is a good tracer player
on houston it's jake on the far this
combos worked well for them before but
as soon as they see the defensive setup
they will just simply swap it away
crucial time lost here
for the outlaws well you know you want
your team to win right they're gonna
have to play what's better
after nerfing her again and again
blizzard gave up
they invented roll lock and force
players to run two of each role instead
of allowing them to play goats
if a character can reshape the way that
players are allowed to play the game
and that's a better option than trying
to balance the character
you know that they're broken as hell
well that's our list
and man was it hard to write there have
been so many broken characters across
our favorite games that
it was actually pretty hard to pick did
we miss your favorite if so
let us know in the comments and while
you're here be sure to like the video
and subscribe to the channel see you
next time
real talk the actual most broken
character in the history of esports is
gambler
actually yeah he's like literally not
even close like this thing was so stupid
his his ability was just like basically
like
like money that was his ability he just
he just literally spawned farm
yeah gambler was was real dumb